all right we're here on the Internet
these are the questions people want to
know us Jay what strategies did you
employ to remain nonpartisan when you
did The Tonight Show I could never
figure out what you were no well ie
because you always put the joke first
and whatever you have to say second that
was really a you know if a joke didn't
necessarily follow my political belief
it was really funny you put it on the
show I mean that was that was sort of
the rule I mean we tried to go 5050 that
there's those people in public media and
they out of the I don't know 30,000
jokes or something it was almost 15,000
against this and for it was pretty crass
pretty no it is a very tribal a divided
come try to go down the line Whoopi oh
you know what about this Jay your first
kiss on screen was with Fran Drescher
that was my first kiss
I can go back to this all night I'm
gonna keep my first kiss on screen with
Hugh Grant what and it was cut out of
the movie what movie was that Richard
Jones's Diary Wow
which I was in and they cut you out we
had a kids I thought he was gonna say I
was just something he did on his iPhone
why what was the scene why was it was a
publishing party it he's beating me like
an old friend and he says do you mind if
I kiss you and this is the stake and I
thought you know yeah and then he goes
for a boom he's too old for you so my
Karli with barbara boxer's announcement
today that she will not seek another
term in the Senate would you consider
running again no I live in Virginia
would you consider running in Virginia
not for Barbara Boxer seat no and what
about presidents are there people
clamoring for you to do that well as a
matter of fact there are some maybe we
have a scoop here news yeah and I mean
I'm seriously considered Wow
we do have a scoop a lot of competition
there in the potty-trained wing and we
were just talking about Jeb Chris
Christie Mitt Romney would you take vice
president well you don't run for vice
president well right but you take it
okay how can we get Elizabeth Warren
well we covered that when it comes to
right on the arrest of these are all
about [ __ ] religion maybe you have a
question bill let's go back to Jay's
25/3 there's like 70 more growing are an
off-the-cuff question my favorite
comedian growing up was Jack Benny I
love Jack Benny my draft number for the
Vietnam War was 273 that's right I had a
question I got a question
okay so question yeah when you're used
to your sort of reg regimented day yeah
you know through in the Tonight Show and
then all of a sudden it's right I don't
have it anymore right
what what does it it's not a problem I
was all as a comedian I was lucky enough
to get a TV show and I thought this may
last a year of my life I don't know how
long was gonna last but I always stayed
a comedian so even when I doing tonight
so I'd go out Thursday Friday Saturday
and Sunday night so I work somewhere so
I oh that was always my thing so now I
just have a little more time off I mean
I love doing it a little Jay used to get
the office at 8:00 and call affiliates
all morning then work on the show all
day and then be still working in the
model like at 2:00 in the morning you
know like a 16 hour in your day to fill
what do you mean I have a little more
free time
while I'm on the road morning all right
thank you everybody thank you better
we'll see you next